UNDERREPORTING AND
BAD MEDIA ARE ONLY TWO OF
THE MANY SYSTEMIC ISSUES
THAT AMERICA'S RAPE VICTIMS
HAVE TO CONTEND WITH.
SAMANTHA BEE FILES THIS
REPORT.
>> AMERICA FACES A LITANY OF
COMPLEX PROBLEMS THAT WE
CAN'T AGREE ON HOW TO FIX.
OUR CRUMBABLING
INFRASTRUCTURE, SIMPLIFYING
OUR BLOATED TAX CODE, IS
SCIENCE EVEN REAL?
HARD STUFF.
BUT CONGRESSWOMAN DEBBIE
WASSERMAN-SCHULTZ THINKS SHE
HAS AN ISSUE THAT NO ONE CAN
DISAGREE WITH.
>> RIGHT NOW A WOMAN DOESN'T
HAVE THE RIGHT ACROSS
AMERICA TO TERMINATE HER
RAPIST'S PARENTAL RIGHTS.
>> NO, THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> IF YOU ARE THE VICTIM OF
RAPE AND YOU CONCEIVE A
CHILD, THEN YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO TERMINATE YOUR
RAPIST'S PARENTAL RIGHTS.
>> SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
CUSTODY, TALKING ABOUT
VISITATION.
>> YES.
>> EVERY OTHER WEEKEND YOU
HAVE TO MEET YOUR RAPIST IN
A DENNY'S PARKING LOT AND HAND
OVER YOUR CHILD.
>> EXACTLY. RIGHT.
>> THIS CANNOT BE REAL.
NO, THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN,
NO, I REFUSE TO BELIEVE
THAT.
>> I SPENT TWO YEARS OF MY
OWN LIFE FIGHTING MY
ATTACKER FOR CUSTODY OF MY
DAUGHTER.
AND IT'S WHAT PROMPTED ME TO GO
TO LAW SCHOOL.
>> OKAY, SO THIS ACTUALLY IS
A THING.
AND SHAUNA PREWITT HAS BEEN A
PUBLIC ADVOCATE TO END THIS
UN[BLEEP] BELIEVABLE
SITUATION.
>> WE KNOW THAT ABOUT 32,000
WOMEN EACH YEAR BECOME
PREGNANT THROUGH RAPE.
AT LEAST A THIRD OF THEM GO
ON TO RAISE THAT CHILD.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT, YOU KNOW,
AT LEAST 10,000 POTENTIAL
CUSTODY BATTLES EVERY SINGLE
YEAR IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> OH, THAT'S VERY
INTERESTING.
OKAY, EXCUSE ME JUST ONE SECOND.
JUST BE RIGHT BACK.
(SCREAMING)
PREWITT'S NUMBERS WERE MAKING MY
BRAIN EXPLODE.
I WAS GOING TO NEED A LITTLE
HELP GETTING THROUGH THIS
STORY.
LUCKILY I WAS PREPARED FOR
JUST SUCH AN EMERGENCY.
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT BABY
CHICKENS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS
WASSERMAN-SCHULTZ INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO FIX THIS.
>> WE DO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THIS BILL IS ENDORSED BY
PRO-LIFE GROUPS AND
PRO-CHOICE GROUPS.
I EXPECTED THAT IF THERE WAS
ANY ISSUE THAT WOULD SAIL
THROUGH WITHOUT A PROBLEM,
THAT IT WOULD BE THIS ONE.
BUT THE BILL DIDN'T EVEN GET
A HEARING.
>> OKAY, NO, NOPE.
>> THE PARENTAL RIGHTS --
>> IT'S GOING
TO BE OKAY.
IT'S GOING TO BE OKAY.
SO WHY DID THIS CAN'T FAIL
BILL FAIL?
>> THERE IS A SMALL
PROVISION IN THE BILL THAT
ACTUALLY SPENDS SOME MONEY.
THE BILL DIDN'T MOVE OVER
THIS SMALL FUNDING ISSUE.
>> SMALL FUNDING, OKAY.
SO THIS IS A WEIRD QUESTION.
BUT HOW MUCH MONEY IS TOO
MUCH MONEY TO STOP RAPISTS
FROM PURSUING THEIR
CUSTODIAL RIGHTS.
>> WELL, LET ME SHARE THE WITH
YOU.
THE BILL AUTHORIZED $5
MILLION PER YEAR FOR FIVE
YEARS.
>> FOR [BLEEP] SAKE.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH THE
GOVERNMENT SPENDS ON
PROMOTING FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES ON SOCIAL MEDIA?
$5 MILLION A YEAR, #GETFRUVED.
SO WE'RE COOL WITH TEAM GRAPES
BUT NOT TEAM HELPING
RAPE VICTIMS? GOT IT.
IN THE MEANTIME
WASSERMAN-SCHULTZ HAS
RE-INTRODUCED HER
BILL AND THINKS THAT THIS TIME
IT MAY PASS.
>> IF IT PASSES THEN NO
WOMAN WILL EVER HAVE TO FACE
THIS NIGHTMARE EVER AGAIN,
PROBLEM SOLVED, RIGHT?
>> WELL, I WISH IT WERE THAT
SIMPLE.
BUT IT'S NOT AUTOMATIC.
IT IS ACTUALLY UP TO THE STATES.
SO WHAT WE DO IN THE BILL IS WE
INCENTIVIZE STATES THAT
DON'T HAVE THIS LAW IN
PLACE.
WE HAVE TO EITHER USE A
CARROT OR A STICK.
IN THIS CASE WE CHOSE A
CARROT.
>> I FEEL LIKE I WOULD HAVE
CHOSEN THE STICK.
>> I KNOW, THE STICK CAN BE
TEMPTING.
>> SO CONSTITUTIONALLY EACH
STATE HAS TO CHANGE ITS OWN
LAWS. QUICK QUESTION, WHY
THE [BLEEP] DO THE STATES
EVEN NEED AN INCENTIVE?
>> I THINK THAT THE PROBLEM
IS THAT IT GOES BACK TO THE
SUSPICION THAT LEGISLATORS
HAVE OF RAPED WOMEN.
AND NOT ONLY THAT, SOME
WOMEN HAVE BEEN THREATENED
BY THEIR ATTACKERS WHO HAVE
SAID IF YOU STOP THE
CRIMINAL PROCESS AGAINST ME
I WILL AGREE NOT TO SEEK ANY
CUSTODY OF PARENTAL RIGHTS.
>> I'M JUST GOING TO GO GET SOME
FRESH AIR.
THAT'S IT, I'M OUT.
I'M OUT OF SHOCK.
OKAY, JUST WALK AND THINK,
THINK AND WALK, OKAY.
WHOOO.
NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN DROPPING CHARGES OR
A CUSTODY BATTLE.
OH MY GOD.
WHERE AM I?
OH, THIS IS PRETTY.
SO SNOWY.
NOT INFURIATINGLY SAD.
YOU KNOW WHAT, WHY WOULD I
LEAVE?
I'LL JUST ENJOY MY TEA.
GROW A BEARD.
WOULD YOU LOOK AT THE LACK
OF SOUL-CRUSHING GOVERNMENT
DYSFUNCTION?
I COULD MAKE A NEW LIFE HERE.
>> SAM.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT?
>> IT'S HASAN MINHAJ FROM THE
DAILY SHOW.
>> I KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
>> YOU NEED TO FINISH THE
PIECE.
>> I'M TO THE GOING BACK.
>> BUT IT'S IMPORTANT.
>> I KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT.
GODDAMN IT.
>> THERE WAS STILL WORK TO
DO.
LISTEN, CAN I BORROW YOUR
RAZOR?
>> I LEFT THAT LADY SITTING
THERE FOR A LONG TIME.
>> OKAY, HERE WE GO.
ARE THERE ANY STATES OUT
THERE DOING THE RIGHT THING
ON THEIR OWN?
>> FLORIDA NOT ONLY HAS A
LAW, IT HAS A TERRIFIC LAW
THAT'S ACTUALLY A MODEL THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO GET REPLICATED IN
A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES.
>> DID YOU JUST SAY FLORIDA?
>> YEAH.
>> I'VE BEEN DOING THIS JOB
FOR A LONG TIME AND I HAVE
NEVER SAID THESE WORDS
BEFORE.
GOOD JOB, FLORIDA!
I KNEW WHAT I HAD TO DO.
TIME FOR A GOOD
OLD-FASHIONED STATE-SHAMING.
>> HI.
IF YOUR STATE IS RED ON THIS
MAP, CALL YOUR LEGISLATOR
AND TELL THEM TO GET THEIR
[BLEEP] TOGETHER.
DON'T LIKE MAPS? HERE ARE THEIR
NAMES.
ALABAMA, ARIZONA, MARYLAND,
MINNESOTA, I'M SO MAD!
THAT FELT BETTER.
AND WHILE WE'RE WAITING, IF
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR ME, I'LL
BE IN MY HAPPY PLACE.
OH YEAH.